[Música]
y ese día fue el parque como todos los
días y había
ya había uno de que hace tiempo que no
ha sido un muchacho muchacho
pero era menor tenían como 10 años
no sé cuántos años tenían
y entonces empecé empezó a decir de qué
de que no me debería hacer ese corte
corte de pelo
después ya yo pensé que era un
comentario y que ya hay días después ya
ya pasó ya nos olvidamos pero seguían al
día siguiente
después de medio que quería pegar y
después ya vinieron todos
y empezaron a pegar
y que lo que te decían de sobre el
soporte de pelo de que de que es un
corte de mujer que no me debería hacer
ese cordón cómo te sentiste
me sentí primer día dije ah
de que no va a ser nada grave
y no sabía que después iba a llegar
hasta la morada
después no estaba en seguridad
no tengo novia seguro no me sentía
seguro
después
después de cuando cuando la policía
y que hablo con los que se pudo los que
los que se quedaron
después cuando terminó todo no me sentía
seguro
no es de seguros ni de regresar a la
casa ni de regresar al parque
quien llamó a la policía
porque llamaste a la policía porque hay
que denunciar la intimidación
no hay que esperar a que se ponga más
grave
desde el comienzo hay que denunciar de
alguna manera si estuvo grave igual te
golpearon
pero pueden llegar a hacer cosas más
graves
entonces para ti era importante digamos
comunicárselo a alguien más a un adulto
y principalmente a algún adulto que
pudiera hacer algo en este caso la
policía
qué hizo la policía
pregunto muchas cosas por teléfono
demoro como 5 minutos todo lo que me
pregunto
y después llegó
llegó y
y también pregunto algunas cosas quiénes
son
[Música]
y para hablar con
hablaron con los que se quedaron
[Música]